hello and welcome to game Sports
coverage of pack South here in San
Antonio Texas Chris waters Alexa ray
Korea how are you doing I'm great how
are you Danny
I'm doing great my favorite part about
PAC said is how we accidentally flew in
a day early and had to make work for
ourselves so we're here to review tomb
rider 3d adventure ride on arcade which
is a video game exclusive to San Antonio
in whoo and ride on a train and shoot
guns and things that are it's kind of
shitty 3d technology crazy what did you
think of that your writer uh so first
off kind of a distinct lack of tombs
just generally this sort of Egyptian
melange I mean there was an Anubis there
were some skeletons but really the sort
of whole aesthetic just seemed to be
what can we cram into this basement to
make it look somewhat exotic my favorite
thing about tomb rider was that for
years I've been raiding tombs up to this
point and despite the fact that that
series has been going on for so long I
never actually written a - and I like to
say if you ever written a tomb before
this I haven't ridden in a tomb before
but sort of piggybacking on what Chris
said I don't know if I believe the tomb
riding experience there was an egregious
use of black light I don't think the
ancient Egyptians had black light so it
just ruined the whole effect the actual
action though let's talk about that yes
because it was shooting a light a little
red laser into glowing color blue
targets yes so bad over the course of
the ride the hit detection was horrible
it was so hard a little tiny pinpoints
and it's super hard we thought we were
getting it but we weren't getting it and
it was just seemed like it was just you
know not very well I don't know tracked
yeah it was a really buggy experienced
me like overall I was trying to hit them
at once a jobs closing one eye and then
trying to shoot with that one and
shooting at the other one but it wasn't
a really far
experience and at the end then the sort
of weird friggin Stargate thing which
was supposed to have like Anubis come up
at the end it didn't actually light up
and the gardens ran out of ammo so I
actually think that it was like it was
pretty buggy and there's nothing where
so you're playing a video game or
whatever this was I'm the game bugs out
right at the end run into bugs you know
you want to finish strong you want to
have that experience you don't want your
guns to all of a sudden go from making
pew pew noises to the tomb riding
experience was just shy of $20 for us do
you think it was worth the do you think
it's worth folks from spending their
hard-earned cash on this you have to
consider that that package also includes
two DLC extras a season pass it comes
with also access to the Guinness Book
World Book Hall of Fame Records Hall
where you just walk around and see a
bunch of wacky facts or the grossly
erroneous facts in some cases yeah I do
game cases so that DLC was pretty buggy
and then the other DLC and Ripley's
haunted adventure yes please want
adventure
that was okay so yeah Tomb Raider 3d and
it's a this is a review so we better
give it a score and Chris what do you
think - why - cuz the peer review
process on GameSpot is very important so
what do you think you know I think given
sort of how we spend a lot of time
talking about the negatives you know
wishing it was more seeing that there
was you know the idea of core of an idea
is there but just the execution was
really poor I'm gonna go with six I see
the effort there but it's good not great
yeah maybe in the sequel they'll fake
they'll address some of our concerns and
personally I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
I'm gonna go for a five that's because I
have a difference yeah I thought two
writer 3d was kind of a piece of hot
[ __ ]
because to play sunset riders afterwards
so I guess if you're an early adopter to
San Antonio there's not many other games
to really play apart from this in the
Alamo but Johnson's I played already so
I guess I mean the LMO is the Alamo is
free to play so and you know it doesn't
have you know it does have depending on
sort of the timed events there was a
person there who let us hold heavy-ass
old gun yes yeah so that was really good
the gun holding off but if they weren't
there you know if that sort of event had
ended by the time you're logging on to
the Alamo the experience just wouldn't
be the same
yeah yeah you need the server loads were
pretty low today as well as so yeah and
so they had the folks at tomb rider 3d
and an exclusive San Antonio game five
out of ten on gamespot.com so for
continuing coverage of local amenities
and pack south stay tuned to games.com
one one